I hate doing something that I don't get
credit for later and what I mean by that
is I want to build something that I
don't have to rebuild again later and so
the idea of making a short that is going
to float today and then disappear into
the ether tomorrow to me taking the
scarce resources of my time and then
having it vanish I couldn't make that
work for me but I realized the content
is not the output the output is the
audience audience is what compounds
audience is what sticks and so you're
not wasting your time on something
that's going to disappear in a while
you're Gathering the scarce resource and
the audience is the thing that pumps
attention over and over again once that
shifted in me I'd stop seeing it as a
waste because I thought if I got one
more person who's going to see this
short or see this long or see this post
or see this tweet or see this whatever
that was the point